hi folks welcome back
um
so we will continue our discussion uh
that we had um that we've been doing for
the past few lectures um we first talked
about time complexity
and then we shifted gears to talk about
space complexity um and we saw we had a
couple of lectures on pspace
uh
kind of culminating in
proving that there were languages which
are piece based complete namely this
tqbf language which is where we started
and then we also proved that there are
problems around involving games such as
the generalized geography game
where determining which side has a
winning strategy is this case piece
based complete at the end of the lecture
uh last time
we
moved to a different regime of space
namely from polynomial space down to log
space
and we introduced the classes l and nl
and so i'm going to begin today's
lecture by reviewing some of the
material on
lnl which i think came a little too
quickly last time
and then we have two important theorems
we're going to cover today
one is about proving that there are
complete languages
for nl um
that has a bearing on the l versus nl
question you know log space
deterministic log space versus
non-deterministic log space that's yet
another unsolved problem in our field
and so there's a notion of a complete
problem from for nl
and um then we're going to prove a
theorem that was in its day very
surprising to people i remember when it
came out um in the 1980s um that nl
in fact is closed under complementation
that the nl class and cohen l class
uh class uh both uh collapse uh to one
that they're equal which is not the way
we believe the situation to be for np
but until someone has a proof that
they're different uh strange things can
happen
okay
um so with that i will um
move myself to uh into the corner
and uh
let's do our review um
so we are
um
in order to talk about
space complexity classes that are
smaller than n we had to introduce a new
model
which was the two tape model where there
was a
read-only tape that had the input on it
um which you normally would think of
something very large
the whole internet or uh
uh
um
you know
something so big that you can't read it
into your kind of your local memory um
and uh
then you have a worktop which is your
your local memory and the way we're
going to think about it in this uh in
the context of
log space is that that work tape is
logarithmic in the size of the input and
that is enough to
have small counters or pointers into the
input um because the reference location
of the input is just needs you only need
login bits to do that
so
we
gave a couple of examples
of the l and n of l and nl languages so
this language of ww reverse
as you may remember
so here is an input um in ww reverse
it's a string follow you know it's a
palindromic string which is of even
length
and so you can make a machine in log
space here that can test whether it's
input is of that form
and the work tape is only all it needs
is a pointer into um
or a couple of pointers that refer to
the corresponding places of the input
that you're looking at at the moment so
you maybe look start out looking at the
two outside a's
and then the and then the this b symbols
that are next to that
and you can write down
on your tape where you're looking
currently
and so that's going to be enough for you
to you may have to zigzag of course back
and forth a lot in order to
do that test but that's completely fine
um using the the model we're not going
to be measuring time we're only going to
be focusing on how much space we're
using
another example that we gave is the path
language
where you're given a graph
and a start node and a target node and
you want to know is there a path is
there a path
um this directed graph that goes from s
to t
and that's a language that's also that
language is an nl
in fact not known to be an l
so
the way that would look shifting to
an input of
uh in the path language you would have a
graph represented say by a sequence of
edges
and a start and a target
and the work tape would keep track of
the current node
um so the nondeterministic machine would
guess a path that takes you from s to t
node by node and the work tape would
keep track of the current node
okay so i hope you have this develop a
little bit of an intuition for these
classes l and n l we're going to be
spending the the entire lecture today
talking about that
um
okay um
so as i mentioned the l and n l um
problem is an unsolved problem and it's
very much
uh analogous to the p versus np problem
except as i mentioned as we'll show
that uh nl and its complement are end up
being the same which is not something
that
seems to be the case for np that we
don't know um
uh
can we think of this as a multi-head
turing machine i'm getting a question
about that which is i think you can um
in fact that's an alternative way that
people look at it
you can think of it as having mult you
know a head is basically needs log space
uh
uh to to store the location to to store
um
you know the the location of where that
head would be so if you imagine having
several different heads on the input
tape you can think of a log space
machine as being sort of a turing
machine that has multiple heads on the
input tape it's it's equivalent um
good question
uh
so let's move on then um
um okay
so one of the things we proved last time
was that uh anything that you can do in
l you can also do in polynomial time um
and i'll answer some of these uh chat
questions in a minute but uh
the
[Music]
um
so the class l is a subset of p this is
easy to prove but i think it's
nevertheless important to see why it's
true because it sort of sets
some definitions of things that we're
going to use later
so
in particular we really need to know the
notion of a configuration
of a
log space machine on an input
um so because the input is
is it does not change
we don't really consider the input to be
part of the configuration
the only thing that's
the the thing that's relevant in the
configuration is the dynamic part of the
machine the state the head locations and
and the work tape contents
uh so we're defining that the mach
configuration for the machine on a
particular input w is those four things
um state the two head locations and the
tape contents and the important thing to
keep in mind for this theorem is that
we have only a polynomial number of
different configurations if you just do
the calculation
uh the main part is the number of
different tape contents as you can have
which is exponential and log n and
that's a polynomial
and so therefore
any
machine that runs in log space provided
it always holds and we always assume our
machines always hold
they can only run for a polynomial
number of steps because that's as many
different configurations as they have
they ran for um say an exponential
number of steps they would have to be
repeating
um configurations and then they would be
loading
okay um
so um
there we go
um
so okay so let me just get back so
there's a somebody asked me a question
which is harder p versus zen p or l
versus n l
you know completely
no idea um
uh it's a
uh
you know
i guess there was a common line of
thinking that um if you're gonna
that it's good to try to
think about
if you're trying to separate classes you
might as well take classes that are as
far apart as one another um uh you know
like if you're trying to prove
if you're comparing p different from np
and p different from p space
maybe p different from p space might be
easier
because
p and p space seem to be even further
apart than p and np
nobody knows and i suspect that there's
something fundamental
about computation that we just don't
understand
and then once somebody makes a
breakthrough and
solves one of those problems a lot of
them are going to get solved in short
order but again
purely speculation
um
okay d
what is d here d would be the size of
the tape alphabet
okay so
this is the number of different tape
contents we have
good
all right um
so let's continue on
another thing we mentioned kind of
quickly in passing but still an
important fact
is that um
savage's theorem works down to the level
of log space
same exact proof
so that means that non-deterministic
log space
is contained in deterministic log
squared space because that's that what
savage's theory does for you it's it it
converts
non-deterministic machines are
deterministic machines at the cost of a
squaring in the amount of space you need
um
and so i'm not going to go through this
in detail
but the same picture that i copied off
an earlier slide
with a simple modification is that
instead of
um
you know that i'm right down the
the the size of the configuration is
going to be now login
because that's how big the
configurations are when you have a
non-deterministic log space
machine
and so simulating that so these are this
would be what the um
uh
the tableau would look like for an nl
machine
um
and then you can simulate that in the
same way by
you know trying all possible
intermediates
and then splitting it
you know
doing the top half and then the bottom
half we're using the space of course
recursively
um
the amount of space you're going to need
is going to be
enough to store for one level of the
recursion uh one configuration and
that's the order log space and then the
number of levels of recursion is going
to be another factor of log n because
that's log to the running time which is
going to be
exponential and log n
which or is polynomial so the total
amount of space that you would need
would be log squared space again this is
sort of saying the proof of savage's
theorem just over again um
so if it's coming too fast for you just
review the proof of savage's theorem and
observe that it works even if the amount
of space that the machine that the
non-deterministic machine starts off
with is log space
all right
um
and uh last thing i'm going to be last
thing in the category of a review
is a uh our uh
theorem that
not only is all of
l within p and that's kind of trivial
kind of immediate you don't even have to
change the machine if you have a log
space machine for some language the very
same machine is a polynomial time
machine for that language because it can
only be running for a polynomial amount
of time but
we have a non-deterministic gene for
some language we're going to have to
change it to become a deterministic
machine that runs in polynomial time and
so we're going to give a deterministic
polynomial times simulation of a
non-deterministic log space machine
um
and uh we kind of did this last time a
little quickly so now if we have some
non-deterministic log space machine so
um
m which decides a language a in in log
space
um
we're going to show how to simulate that
machine
um with a deterministic polynomial time
machine
and the key idea which which is going to
come up
um
uh in in a later theorem so
good to understand it now not only here
but to uh to understand it uh for uh for
the next theorem that's coming is the
notion of a configuration graph i was
sort of thinking about calling it a
computation graph but now on further
reflection i think configuration graph
maybe is the more suggestive term so
let's stick with that
um so configuration graph
for a
machine on an input
is just a set of all configurations that
the machine has all the possible
different configurations um the machine
can have
with edges connecting configurations
that correspond to legal moves of the
machine
so here's some configuration this is a
snapshot of the machine at a moment in
time here is some other configuration
another snapshot of the machine at a
moment in time
and you're going to draw an edge between
ci and cj if cj could follow in one step
from ci and you could tell by just
looking at the configurations whether
that could be possible obviously the
head has to be one place over
in cj from where it was in ci and it has
to be updated according to the rules of
the machine so you can tell
whether um you know you so you you could
fill out this graph you could write down
all the possible configurations
and you can put the edges down now the
point is that when we have a log space
machine
we don't have too many config possible
configurations there's only a polynomial
number
so the size of this whole graph is
polynomial
so our polynomial time simulation is
going to write down that entire
configuration graph of the log space
machine on its input
there are
many configurations that can be only
polynomially many so you can write down
all those configurations as the nodes
and then go look at each pair of nodes
whether this configuration could lead to
that configuration according to you know
it's a non-deterministic machine so a
configuration could go to several
different loc you know there could be
several different ways to go but those
are just several different outgoing
edges from a particular node in this
graph representing the configuration
which might have several different legal
successors in the non-deterministic
computation
okay now the important thing here is
that m accepts its input w
exactly when there is a path
this configuration graph that takes you
from the start configuration to the
accept configuration and as i mentioned
let's assume as we've been doing that
the machine i should have put it here
but i didn't but the the machine um when
it is about to accept it erases its work
tape and moves both of its head
to the home position at the left end of
the tape so there's just one accepting
configuration you have to worry about it
just makes life simpler
um
so there's going to be a start
configuration a single accept
configuration
in this configuration graph and now
there's going to be a path
indicated here that connects the start
configuration to the accept
configuration
if and only if m accepts w
because that path
is the sequence of configurations that
the machine would go through
if you launched it on w it would start
at the start
and there might be several different
ways to go
but if there is one of them that leads
you to an accept that's going to
correspond to a branch of the
computation that's accepting
okay so
that's tells us what the polynomial time
algorithm is
it says you on input w you you
construct that configuration graph for m
on w
g sub mw
and you test whether there's a path from
c star to c except using any polynomial
time
um
you know depth first searched or breadth
first search
you know um algorithm for testing
whether there's a connection
passed in a graph
and if there is such a path you accept
because that means the machine m
accepted and if there was no path you
reject because then m
uh must have not accepted
and therefore you have a uh polynomial
time simulation of your
non-deterministic log space machine m
okay
how are we doing
okay so that tells us
that nl
is contained within p
and also l is contained with an nl as
before
so we have kind of a this
hierarchy of classes
um
now you can even talk about not only is
l different from n l even as l different
from p is it possible that anything that
you can do in polynomial time you can do
a lot of space
don't know
open question
okay i'm getting a very good question
here just now
why is this construction taking
log space
it doesn't
this instruction takes polynomial time
this can this algorithm here
is not
a
polynomial this is not a log space
algorithm that i'm giving you i'm giving
a polynomial time algorithm for
stimulating a non-deterministic log
space machine
now later on you know i don't want to
confuse the issue right now
for this particular
slide
all i need to do is construct that
graph in polynomial time it's a you know
it's a polynomial size graph i can't
store that whole graph in a log space
memory
okay so question here
um
[Music]
you know we can see that listing out to
the nodes and edges would be polynomial
time
but how do we actually provide structure
to this graph representation i don't
even know what that means so if you can
clarify that for me then maybe i can try
to answer it but you know a graph is
just a list of nodes and a list of edges
after that
we know what the graph is
i mean you know you may like a picture
but the machine doesn't need a picture
um
you know our definition of
you know we we just represent these
things as um
uh
and in the end
so please clarify if you want me to i'll
try to i'll answer it at the next at the
next pause
um
i'm grateful for all the questions
because i'm sure
any question that any of you have
another 20 of you also have so it's um
questions are good
uh don't don't don't be bashful
um and also ask the tas if i could
become overloaded
um
okay now we're going to shift gears into
some new material
all right
um we're going to talk about
the notion that
uh sort of thinking about analogous to
the p versus np problem where there were
these np complete problems
now we have the l versus nl problem
there are going to be nl complete
problems
and that kind of capture the essence of
nl the way np complete problems capture
the essence of np in a sense and that
all other problems in np are reducible
to them so they're kind of like the
hardest np problems here we're going to
have exactly analogous situation for
nl um
where we're going to uh show problems
where
all other nl problems are reducible to
them so if you can kind of solve one of
them like
solve one of these nl complete problems
in log space deterministically then you
solve all of nl problems in log space
deterministically
so
um it's a very similar looking
definition to what we had before
uh it's an l complete if it's in nl and
then all other
languages in nl should be
reducible but now we have a new notion
here
um
with an l instead of a p
now before when we talked about np
completeness we had polynomial time
reducibility
that's not going to work anymore
because if you
remember
nl
is a subset of p so all nl languages are
polynomial are our languages in p
and if we're talking about if we use
polynomial time reducibility all
languages and p are reducible to each
other
we need to have a notion of reducibility
which is kind of weaker than the class
um
and so
uh polynomial time reducibility just
would not work here because everything
would become nl complete because
everything is introducible to each other
so we need to have a weaker notion we're
going to use log space reducibility
which we have to define
[Music]
so here for that we're going to have to
talk about the notion of a function that
you can compute
in log space
okay and it's a little tricky here
just like when we talked about language
recognition in log space where we had
the work tape had to be smaller than the
input tape
because the inputs can be large the work
area is small
now the output also
could be large relative to the work area
so we're going to have a three tape
model
where there's the input
is going to be a read only
the output is a write only it's like a
printer
it's something you can only write on but
you can't read back because otherwise
you can cheat by using the output as a
kind of storage
and then you have your storage area
which is your your read write work tape
okay so this would call this
you know the traditional name of this is
a log space transducer
so it you know it converts inputs to
outputs but uses only log space for its
working memory
okay so
the input tape has stores in bit and
symbols
the
work tape stores log n symbols order
login symbols and then we have the
output tape i mean you want to think
about how big can they
there's going to be a check in coming to
kind of uh
ask you how big could the memory could
the output be but that also will save
that for the end if you can mult that
over if you're
uh want to think ahead
okay um
[Music]
so we think of a log space
transducer as
computing a function which is just a
mapping from the input to the output
that the transducer provides for you
a transducer transducer is a
deterministic machine by the way
so
you take the transducer
you give it a w
and you turn it on
and then it out holds with f of w on its
output tape that's what it means to be
computing the function f
okay and we'll say that
a is log space reducible to b
using the l subscript symbol on the less
than or equal to sign if it's mapping
reducible to b but by a reduction
function that's computable in log space
just the same way we defined polynomial
time reducibility but there we insisted
that the reduction function was
computable in polynomial time
um
okay just
quickly i got a question again uh
you know why why log space here because
polynomial time would be too powerful
for doing reductions
uh
internal to p
every
language
in p is reducible to every other
language in p and so everything in nl
would be reducible to everything else in
l with a polynomial time reducibility
and so that would not be an interesting
notion we have to use a weaker notion
than that
a weaker
kind of reduction
um
using a weaker model
so that you don't get
the otherwise the the the re reduction
function would be able to answer
whether um
you know it would be able to solve the
problem a itself if we had a polynomial
time reduction and we're mapping things
from
logs in you know nl to other problems in
nl the reduction would solve the problem
that's not what you want
the reduction should be constrained only
to be able to do simple transformations
on the
uh
on the problem not to solve the problem
anyway you have to look at that you know
this is an issue that's come up before
when we talked about um what's the right
notion of reduction to use for piece
based completeness same exact discussion
okay
now there is an issue here though uh
that we have to be careful of when we
have a being log space reducible to b
and b and l
then what you want
um
[Music]
uh
if if a is log space reducible to b and
b and l then you want a to be in l
that's the same pattern we've always had
for reductions if a is reducible to b
and b is easy then a is easy so here in
the notion of easy as being an l
um
now if you remember the proof of that
that we had from before
which i'll just
put out for you is that
um
to show a log space solver for a
um
uh
you take an input w
and now if a is reducible to b
you do compute the reduction and then
you run the decider for b
um so if we're assuming a is reducible
to b and b is in l so b has a log space
decider
you you take your
w which you want to know is it in a
you map it over to the b a b problem
using the reduction function
and then
you solve it using the decider for b
and you give the same answer
now this actually doesn't work
anymore
it doesn't work in an obvious way
because if you if you're following me
i hope you most of you are um
there is a
there is a problem here
which
because we're trying to give a
a log space algorithm for a
and that algorithm is going to be
computing
this reduction function mapping w to f
of w
f of w might itself be very large
as this picture suggests here
you may not be able to store
f of w
in
the log space memory
for the machine that's deciding any
so
this
is an obstacle
that we need to solve
in order to prove this theorem which we
need
because that's the whole justification
for doing these reducibilities
um
should be a familiar looking kind of
line to what we've seen before
uh so we don't have space to store f of
w what do we do
and and i'll also mention that this is
going to be relevant to one of your
homework problems
so
what do we do we don't have space to
store the intermediate result
that we need in order to solve the
problem you know we started with w
now we need to test if f of w is in b
that can run in log space but just
simply getting your hands on f w how do
you what do you do about that
um
so what we're going to do is the
following
is
the decider
um
the the decider for b
which needs f of w
um
because it's deciding if f of w is in b
um
it doesn't need all of f w sitting there
in front of it all at once
if you think about how the turing
machine operates
on its input it only looks at one symbol
at a time
you know it starts out reading the left
foremost symbol of f w
then maybe he moves his head right moves
the second symbol of f of w then the
third symbol of f of w maybe gets up to
the
uh tenth symbol of f w maybe it moves
his head back and goes to the ninth
symbol in the eighth symbol but the
turing machine's head
you know which is deciding b only looks
at one symbol of f of w at a time
uh so instead of writing down all of f w
the idea is
that we are going to
compute the individual symbols of f of w
that we need
only at the moment we need them
so if
the
decider for b
[Music]
is reading the tenth symbol of f w
we fire up
um
the
transducer
on w
and as it's writing out its output which
we don't have space to store anymore we
throw away all of the output values
until we get to the tenth one
and then we said ah the tenth one is
whatever
is a c
whatever the value is now we feed that
into the uh decider for b
we can now simulate that decider for one
more step
now the decider says now i need the 11th
um symbol of f w okay now we can run the
run the machine for one more place
um
but if it needs but we don't even have
to do it if you know we the i think the
better way to think about it is every
time
that decider for b needs another symbol
we start the transducer over again
and just keep
throw away everything except for that
one symbol output that we that we need
so every time we do another step of
simulating b
we're going to have to re-run the
transducer from the beginning just to
recompute
that or compute maybe for the first time
or recomputed if we need it subsequently
this is going to be slow but we don't
care
um
to uh recompute that that symbol that
that the
uh simulator that the
decider for b uh requires okay so i'm
saying that over here recompute the
symbols of f of w as needed
okay so let me let's take a couple of
questions and then we're going to move
to a check-in
so
so somebody's asking why we why did we
have to introduce transducer for log
space reducibility when we didn't do it
for polynomial time reducibility we
could have for polynomial time
reducibility but we didn't need to
because we could just all do it on the
same tape
the problem is for log space the tape is
the work tape is too small to hold the
input on the output
so we can't um you know since we're only
working we have a log n bound that we
have to work within
uh we need to uh separate those
functions from the work functions the
input function and the output function
in the case if we had if we have more
than
um you know the amount of resource we
have either time or space was at least n
then we could just lump them all
together and have that one tape do multi
you know uh multiple functions
um and somebody's asking me here yeah
this is mapping reducibility this m this
is what we from the notion we saw before
okay
um does f of w lie on the input tape of
b
well yes
so
we are
good question so f of w
you know because
what are we doing we're trying to find a
decider for a here using the decider for
b
and the and the mapping from a to b
um
the reduction from a to b
so the decider for b expects to find
its input on an input tape
um
that input is going to be f of w
but but you know we have to
get the effect of that without actually
writing down that input tape because we
don't have enough room to write down the
input tape for the decider for the b
decider because that could be very large
and we
we only have
we have no place to put the f of w
to think about what's going on here
we're making a log space machine whose
input is w
has to compute f of w as an intermediate
value
to feed it into the beta side
that is not going to be
possible to hold on to that whole f of w
at one to altogether because it's too
big but that doesn't mean we don't need
it we only need one symbol at a time
which we can recompute
um okay so let's see
um so somebody says can we just ensure
that the output tape is order n so we
don't need more tape than the input
order n is still going to be too big
where you're going to put that output
even if it's or just order n first of
all no the answer is no we can't because
there are going to be reductions which
are bigger than that
but the other
question is if you know can we just
ensure that the output is order n
you can't put the output on the input
tape
the input tape is read only the output
tape is right only
so there's no place to
just even if the output is just as big
as the input it doesn't help you
if the output is only log in okay then
we could do it but that's not going to
be interesting for us the obvious the
you know you're going to need
for these log space reductions big
outputs
um as we'll see in a minute
uh
what's the running time for this log
space reduction it's all going to be
polynomial it's all going to be a log
space algorithm so it's all going to be
polynomial
um
is there any
np completeness reduction which can be
done in log space
all of the np com all typical
np completeness reductions those
polynomial time reductions they all can
be done in log space because
they are
reductions tend to be very simple
transformations
and log space is going to be enough to
do all of them
um
okay uh
i can't answer the second part of that
too that's too complicated and i think
we should move on um so um
let's let's look at the first check in
here
uh so if we have a log space transducer
that computes f
and if you defeated inputs of length n
how how big can the outputs be actually
um
so what you think about that and give me
an answer i'll give you a minute uh
to answer this question
oh this is a tough one
these are this is i i i let me just say
up front
there are
i i struggle with this lecture
because some especially the stuff in the
second half it's kind of hard it's i
wouldn't say it's
it's technical
but conceptually i think some of the
material is is is a little harder maybe
in part because people are not used to
thinking about um
memory complexity or space complexity
even though i don't see why i mean i
think it's an important resource to be
considering but i think it's less common
and i think there's some um discomfort
with that okay the so we're just about
done here um
five more seconds please
all right
about to wrap
wrap the chicken oh one two three
all right
so yes the correct answer
is c
um
as i mentioned
uh
you know we're going to want to have
outputs that are
larger than log n and there's no reason
why they
wouldn't be able to be larger than log n
according to the definition that i gave
you gave you there's no
bound on the output we're only measuring
the the run the running space of this
algorithm in terms of its um work tape
the input and output tapes don't count
so they could be more than log n they
can be more than n polynomial is the
right answer why
because
a log space transducer
um if you just ignore the output it's
just an ordinary log space machine and i
know it can only run for a polynomial
number of steps without an end up going
into a loop the same argument that we
gave for that before applies here as
well um so if it's going to exceed a
polynomial number of steps it's never
going to hold
and so that's going to be
not allow it it's got a halt with the
output on the output tape and so that
it'll be
disqualified as a
as a log space transducer
if it doesn't uh if it doesn't hold so
it can't be anything longer than
polynomial
it's a good thing to think about to
understand
okay so let's continue
um
so we're going to show that the path
problem is nl-complete now we had we
defined nl completeness
and we've we've seen the path problem
before
um
and we're now going to show that path
occupies that very special position for
nl namely that it's an ml complete
problem
um
so if you can
solve the path problem
deterministically in log space you have
gotten a big result
who knows how to do that
and it would it would collapse all of n
l down to path down to log space if you
could do
path in log space deterministically
um
okay so let's see why that is so first
of all the two components of being
complete are being in the language and
the reduction part so in the language
we've shown already
uh now we want to show that for any
language other language in nl
it's going to be
log space reducible to path
in a certain sense
this may not
feel so surprising
thinking back
to our proof
that nl
is in
uh is a subset of p
because we managed to convert
any nl
machine
and any the running of any l machine to
a path problem
that the the polynomial time machine
then solved um
and so
it's really the same idea that says that
path
really captures
any
you know any um
uh
any and any nl machine
you know the computation of any nl
machine really can be seen as a path
problem um where the nodes are the
configurations of the machine
um so let's just see how let me just try
to go through that if that wasn't super
clear which i'm not sure it was
um
so suppose we have a machine decided by
a language decided by
non-deterministic you know an nl machine
and non-deterministic machine in log
space
um
again i should have put this before but
we're going to modify m to
erase its work tape and move its head to
the left and on accepting so um it has a
unique
accepting configuration
um
now i'm going to give the log space
reduction
that maps
our language a which is in nl to the
path language
so thinking about what that means i'm
going to take an input w
which may or may not be an a and produce
for you a graph with a start and target
node
starting targeted nodes
um
where
w is going to be in the language if and
only if g has a path from s to t
and what do you think that graph is
going to be
that's going to be the configuration
graph for the machine
that
decides a
okay
so um
[Music]
that is uh
how it's going to look so here maybe
here's a picture right
so f of w
where w again is your problem about
membership in a is going to become a pr
a problem about membership and path and
it's just going to be the configuration
graph for m on w
um
now
what's left is to
show that we can do this conversion in
with a log space transducer so it's a
log space computable
reduction
um
so let's just try to go through that
quickly um
it's not conceptually not super hard um
[Music]
so
here's our transducer let's just think
about what it needs to do it needs to
take an input w
and convert that f of w
to
this thing here
the computation graph of m on w the
configuration graph m on w the start and
except configuration so that's going to
look like this down here that's what we
want to eventually appear on the output
tape
[Music]
so the way we're going to achieve that
we all only have a small
log space order log space work tape and
the way we're going to be able to
produce this output
is you know the
the
configuration
graph it's just a series of edges which
are
say you can go from this configuration
to that configuration in one step so
what we're going to do
is on our work tape we're going to go
through all possible pairs of
configurations again just in some
like odometer order just by
looking at all possible strings really
of length order log n that are big
enough to represent two configurations
every once in a while it's going to be
actually a pair of configurations at
that point we look at those two
configurations look at m and see can
this configuration go to that
configuration if yes you print it out on
the output if no you just move on to the
next pair of configurations
so it's not and then at the end you
write down the start and accept
configurations so i've i've indicated
that here here is the transducer it says
on input w for all pairs of
configurations that now this is getting
written down on the right work tape you
output those pairs which are legal moves
for m
and then finally i'll put the starting
accept that's it
so let's just see
let me take any questions here
um
why do we need special except state for
m well we want to have i think you mean
accepting configuration i just want to
have this i don't want to have a
multiplicity of different possible
accepting configurations because then
it's not really a path problem then it
becomes a question of can i get from the
start to one of those accepting you know
nodes representing accepting
configurations that's a little messy i
can fix it but the simplest fix is just
to make there be a single accepting
configuration
um
well why do i output starting except at
the end of the output tape that's the
way i write down my path problem it's a
graph followed by a start node and a
target node so that's
i have to
follow that form that's oh i'm not sure
what you're asking you want me that you
want me to put that first
i'm not sure what the or or why at all
because it has to be a
um
you know here it is here's the output
i'm looking for
um
okay
do the three
do the read write work tape here store
pointers to configuration or some sort
of counter no they store the actual
configuration
the configuration
for m
is just think about what it is it's a
log space size object
it's an it's a tape for m
it's a location of its heads
and it stayed
so you're just gonna write down that
stuff over right over here on the left
side of this uh
this left slot and on the right slide
you're gonna write another configuration
for m on w um
and um you're going to just then put the
edges in accordingly
okay so somebody did that help you know
some again is asking why is the
configuration on the log space
it's just a tape it's a log space tape
that's the main thing in the
configuration of the tape
um
on the read white work tape do we have
do we only write two configurations at
once yeah we're just writing down a
candidate edge
that we're going to output onto the
output tape so that's why we have two
configurations i want to know can i get
from this configuration to that
configuration if yes i print it out
print out that pair that's an edge in my
config
my my configuration graph which is what
i'm supposed to be outputting here
can there be mo
okay when we move on
again direct questions to our tas who
are
uh would be more than happy to help you
uh
and we will let me just quickly give i'm
a little running a little tight here
time wise but let's just see
um here's an example of showing some
other problem is nl complete you have a
homework problem on that so i thought i
want to give you an example maybe we can
just defer this to the recitation if so
maybe we'll try to do this a little
quickly um
to save us some time but
the two-set problem which is just like
the three sad problem except with two
literals per clause
curiously the complement of that problem
so the unsatisfiable problem um
uh
formulas that form an nl complete
language
um
and so first of all you have to show
it's in nl we're not going to do that
it's a nice exercise it's not totally
trivial to do um
but it it's
i you might want to try that
um
we're going to show that path is
reducible
to the complement of two set
we've got to give a reduction
that gives converts graphs to formulas
where there is a path now when the
formula is unsatisfied
and that um what's going to happen is
the path is going to correspond to a
sequence of implications
in the formula which yields a
contradiction and forces it to be
unsatisfiable
again this is going to come a little
fast but um and then you know maybe we
can discuss that over the break which is
next
so
every node in g
is going to have associated variable in
the formula so there's a variable for
every one of the nodes for every edge
there's going to be a clause
of implication connecting those two
associated nodes so if there's an edge
from u to v then there's going to be an
implication in the formula that says uh
if x u is true then x v is true
um and note that that's
equivalent to the more conventional ways
xu complement or xv these are logically
equivalent so i'm not cheating you here
in terms of being a two sat problem they
really just look like this
and lastly i'm going to put uh
two additional clauses
it's a
x for the start variable um from the
start node s
here s
uh i want i want to force that one to be
true so it's x since i want to have two
exactly two per clause as xs or xs so
that forces
x
that that variable true
and similarly and and lastly
if t is true
that's going to force
um the the
the if x t is true that's going to force
x s to be false
so now if there's actually a path
in the graph
that goes from s to t
there's going to be a sequence of
implications starting out with s being
true
forcing other things being true
including forcing t to be true which
then forces s to be false
and that's our contradiction which shows
that the formula cannot be satisfied
um
so now you have to prove that this works
um
as i said you can for the forward
direction if there is a path you follow
the implications to get a contradiction
for the reverse
let me not uh spend time here you can
i'll leave this to you to think about
offline um
but if there is no path there is a way
of assigning the variables
to true and false
to make a
satisfying assignment to the formula
so that gives the other direction
okay
um
so
and you can show it's computable in log
space that's very simple because a very
simple
transformation there
okay so
uh i think we're gonna
move on to the break
um
and uh
i'm happy to take
questions at this point about this
does the configuration
going back include the input no the
configuration does not i mean as i said
the configuration for m on w
is
the state
the head positions
and the work tape contents not the input
tape because then you would be
it's not there for a reason the input is
huge
um but you don't need the input there
because the input is going to be
constant for everybody everybody can
look at that input which is a fixed uh
sort of external thing um
uh somebody's asking me are there any np
complete problems in
[Music]
there are definitely np complete
theories some
i don't i don't know
um
uh there are some problems in number
three where it's you know like factoring
where we don't know the status somewhere
between p and np
um
you know it's formulated as a language
of course but uh there are problems in
um
solving certain kinds of
uh equations uh
low degree equations um
that that uh i don't remember now
exactly those are
actually known to be np-complete um
now us but nl-completa
i don't know if they're nl-complete
number theory problems
oh good question somebody's asking me
does nl also have an alternative
definition using certificates or
witnesses
yeah
um
yes
sort of
um
for nl
you can make a certificate which is
again polynomial size certificate
but it has to be you're only allowed to
read it with a one-way
head
so it's like a
one-way
one-way certificate um
so it had to be you can only process it
in a certain way that's that's a nice
exercise actually itself um
but anyway
let us uh
we are
now um
johnny
um
and we're going to move back we're going
to continue
so everybody return
uh
this is um
what's next on the agenda proving that
nl equals cohen l this is a hard proof
um
i'm going to try to break it down as
much as i can and let's hope
you
you get
i i hope you i hope you get it uh i'll
try to be as helpful as i can as i can
okay um but if you
if you're finding it tough you won't be
alone
so um
first of all
we're going to show
the way we're going to solve this is by
showing that the complement of path is
solvable in n in nl
because the complement of path is just
as path is complete for nl
the complement is complete for co and l
um
and so by doing that problem in nl we're
going to reduce all of co all of cohen l
will be reducible to problems in n l and
so therefore will be n n l colon l will
be then inside n l and then uh n l is
going to be equal to coin um
if that sequence of logical connections
um
uh
is not clear don't worry
the point is is that we want
go back and figure out why that's enough
later but
what this means is we want to give a
non-deterministic machine
which will accept when there is no path
from s to t
okay
and and please don't say why don't we
just take the machine
for path and flip the answer you can't
do that with a non-deterministic machine
um so you better if you're thinking that
that's allowed go back and review
non-determinism um so you want to make a
non-deterministic machine which is going
to accept when there's no path so some
branch is going to make a sequence of
guesses
and it has to be sure that there's no
path and then it's going to be um and
then it can accept when there's no path
now if you can find a way of like making
a separator something that cuts the
graph in half and separates s from t
then you would be good um the only
problem is
um
there's no
um there's no obvious way of doing that
because those kind of separators even if
they were
probably too big to write down in um
in log space
so
i'm going to give you a completely
different way of doing it
and um
i'm going to make this is a little
different presentation than what's in
the book i think hopefully this is a
little
longer and therefore a little clearer
um
we'll see uh so first of all i'm going
to define a notion of a
non-deterministic machine computing a
function
and that's a simple idea
what you want is
on the different branches so you have
some function f
which has for every w there's a output f
of w
um
and what and the non-deterministic
machine
can operate
that
on all of its branches
it's allowed to either give f of w
or say reject mean punt this is or say i
don't know
so every branch has to give the right f
the right answer so all the all the
branches that give an answer have to
agree because there's only one right
answer all the branches that give an
answer have to give the right answer or
they can say i don't know
um
the only thing is you have to also say
that at least one of the branches
actually gives an answer
so somebody doesn't cannot reject
somebody cannot say i don't know
um
so at least one of the branches gives an
answer
and gives the gives the answer and all
the other branches can either give
the answer or they can say they can just
reject
okay um but there's no notion of
accepting there's just an accept notion
of this non-deterministic machine on
some branches giving the output value
and other branches just punting and
saying reject
maybe reject is the wrong word i could
just say punt
um
[Music]
all right uh so we're going to be
talking about functions that you can
compute
with
um
non-deterministic machines with nl
machines uh in particular
all right so we're going to look at this
path
language this path function now now this
is not exactly the same as the path
language this is a function here
written with lowercase
so given a graph s and t
i'm going to say yes if there is a path
and no if there's no path and this is a
function now which is going to output
yes or no
not a language
um
this is a function it's very closely
related i understand
you know so if you can solve the
function you can do the language
um but what we're going to give is a
nl
machine a non-deterministic machine
which is going to compute this function
and therefore you can use that to do the
path language
two important things for us is here if g
is some graph and here's the starting
node s
um r is all of the nodes that you can
reach from s this is a this is a some
uh collection of nodes
and c which stands for count is the
number of reachable nodes
so i've written it down here more if you
like it more formally
uh r is the number is the collection of
nodes for where the from for which
there's a path from s to that node
and c is the size of r
so this you have to understand these two
because we're going to be playing with
this for the next three slides
okay
now first of all this is kind of a
little bit of an exercise theorem but
it's still going to be a useful fact
that we're going to end up
needing later but it's also a little bit
of just to test your understanding
suppose
there's some
nl machine which computes this path
function so
um you know
on the different branches of the
non-determinism given
you know
a graph a g s and t
there are going to be some branches
which may output yes or some branches
that may open no and other branches may
say i don't know but the machine always
has to give the right answer if it's
going to give any answer so all branches
either have to say yes or all branches
all branches have to say yes or punt
or all branches have to say no
or punt
because one of those answers is going to
be the right answer
um
so suppose i have a way of computing
path
by an nl machine
then can i also compute
can i make some other nl machine which
computes the count of the number of
reached uh the number of nodes reachable
so if i can test if a node is reachable
can i figure out how many nodes are
reachable
this is supposed to be easy
this is kind of a little bit of a
practice
um so if i can figure out if nodes are
reachable yes or no then i can say
figure out how many nodes are reachable
you just go through them one by one
testing if they're reachable and count
the ones that are
that's the only that's that's all i have
in mind
so
start with a counter that's set to zero
initially and go through each of the
nodes of g one by one
and i use my nl machine
that computes path that's what i mean by
this part
um so i test if
um
the nl machine says yes there is a path
then i increase the counter
and if it says there's no path
then i just
continue without increasing the count
now when i'm running my nl machine to
calculate this compute this function
that nl machine might punt might reject
sometimes on some branches that's okay
you know i'm i'm also allowed i'm also
an nl machine i'm computing
a value um
and i also might punt on some uh
branches
uh
so at the end i'm gonna output that
count
okay
so what i'm gonna prove
next is the converse of this
and that's and that's the magical hard
part that if i can compute the count
then i can com then i can do the test uh
of whether
um
uh individual nodes are uh connected
have a path from s
um
okay so let's just see
somebody's asking
in
non-deterministic machines
uh so you know like m is not allowed to
loop no
if a machine if any one of these
machines like an nl machine loops it's
going to be going forever that's not
allowed so no looping
um i'm sure that's relevant but
no lu no looping
but i'm more worried is that you
understand this uh theorem here um i
think we have a check incoming let's
let's see
okay this might be helpful
so consider the statement that path
complement is in l that's what we're
trying to prove
and also that some nl machine can
compute the path function
these are going to be related
facts
which one can we prove from the other
easily
i mean they're both going to be true so
in some sense it's trivial but i want to
know which one can we prove kind of
immediately without doing much work
that
i can solve this path problem in nl the
complement of the path problem in an l
or that i can compute the path function
in analysis so what do you think um
[Music]
okay
um
almost done here
yeah
ending
uh
you guys didn't do well
[Laughter]
that's okay uh the actually the right
answer is c
um most of you got that if i can solve
the path function
sorry the yes no value i can use that
now to solve both
path and path complement that you know
uh that's seems more
clear-cut
but suppose i can solve the path
complement problem in an nl and i can
also i also know i can solve the path
problem in nl that that we've already
shown um
so knowing both of those
um
you know if i given a g s and t what i
can do is not deterministically pick
which of those two directions
you know i pick
i'm going to guess well
uh it's in path or it's in the
complement of path so there are two
different non-deterministic ways to go
one of those is going to always end up
rejecting um and so that's going to end
up hunting the other direction is going
to sometimes end up accepting and
sometimes punting and based upon whether
which side is ends up
one or the other is going to have some
except um
is going to be accepting and so
the one that's accepting is going to
tell me whether to answer yes or no
so actually both directions
um
both implications follow pretty easily
um
okay
anyway let's see let's try
uh to show
this is this is the hard part
uh and we have five minutes let's see
how far we can get
um
so
this theorem works by magic
so uh
you know it kind of blew everybody's
mind when it was first came out so let's
just see it's really not that hard
but it's sort of
it's kind of twisted
um
so suppose there some machine can
compute c the count
the number reachable from s
i'm going to use that to solve path um
the path function
to test yes i can
but yes if there is a path or no there
is no path for each node
so if i know how many nodes are
reachable
then i can solve now for individual
nodes
which is
strange
that you can do that
now i'm not telling you how to compute c
that's for later
which i probably won't get to but just
imagine pretend we can somehow figure
out
what the count is of the number of
reachable nodes
okay
so here is my uh
non-deterministic algorithm
for computing path
first i'm going to compute c
or let's say c is given
and now
maybe the best thing to do is to try to
give you the idea up front
um what we're going to do since we're a
little short on time what we're going to
do
is
suppose i tell you
there are in this graph
a hundred nodes reachable from s so c is
a hundred
there's a hundred reachable nodes
now i wanna know
i say well i i i i don't really that's
all very nice but i'd like to know this
particular node t
is that reachable from x
now you're i'm a non-deterministic
machine
now if t was reachable
then i'd be fine because
non-deterministically i don't even care
about the hundred i take and
non-deterministically on some branch
starting from s i'm gonna hit t
and that branch is gonna say yes the
other branches
maybe they'll punt
but some branches are going to get the
right answer
the problem is suppose t is not
reachable
then you want some branches to say no
and how could that branch ever say no
unless it's sure
that t is not reachable and how can one
branch be sure
the idea is this
suppose i know that there are a hundred
reachable nodes
what i'm what what i'm going to do
non-deterministically
is i'm going to guess those hundred
nodes one by one
can't keep you can't store them all
because it could be a hundred could be a
big number
uh i'm gonna guess them one by one i'm
gonna guess them and every time i guess
a note
i'm going to prove it's reachable by
guessing the path that shows it's
reachable
so i'm going to guess 100 nodes
prove that they're reachable
and then see is was t one of those
reachable notes
if it was well and then i would have
found it and i would notice a yes
but if t was not one of the hundred
reachable nodes and i know there's only
a hundred
so if t is not one of those nodes and i
in other words if i found them all
and t wasn't one of them then i know
it's not reachable
and that's how using the count
i can be sure that certain nodes are not
reachable because i just find all the
ones that are prove that they are check
that the count agrees with what i was
given and then say no t is not reachable
if it's not one of those
nodes that i've found
you know to be reachable which adds up
to my given count
that's the whole idea
of course how do you get the count
oddly enough it just it's really it's
kind of the same idea repeat it over and
over again
but uh i guess we'll have to do that
next time so let's just write this down
and we'll kind of uh use that as the
beginning of uh thursday's lecture um so
we're going to go through each node u
one by one
we're now gonna guess for each node
whether there's a path to it or not
so i'm gonna call it either p or n
um again
this is now think about my 100 nodes i'm
going to be guessing all 100 nodes
uh i'm going to nondeterministically
pick a path
um from that node that i guessed is
reachable so if i guess a node there is
a path
i'm going to confirm there's a path by
non-deterministically picking it
if i don't find that path i just reject
punt on that on that on that branch
if that
path that i found actually led me to t
that so you that node that i'm working
on is currently t then i know to accept
but otherwise i'm just going to count
the number of nodes that i find are
reachable
um
if i've guessed that u is not reachable
i'm just going to skip it
um at the end i see whether the number
of nodes that i've determined are
reachable agrees with my original count
c
so does k equal c or not
if it doesn't equal they're not equal
then i didn't find all the reachable
nodes
i didn't guess right
and so
i punt i say well i bad branch of the
non-determinism i i just give up
but some branch of the non-determinism
is going to guess all of the correct
nodes which are reachable
and then
if t hadn't been found already to be one
of them at this point i know t is not
reachable and so i cannot put no
okay
um so that's
that's the that's the whole thing um
what is m m is the
good question m is the number of nodes
of the graph i should have said that so
you don't want to go to you don't want
to get into a loop
um so you better
cut off your picking of a path
uh to some cutoff value so you're going
to cut it off at m which is the number
of nodes which is longer going to be
long enough actually that
uh we're going to play with that in a
bit later but um
okay let's just see how do i know i did
not visit the same node twice when
counting because i'm just going to go
through all of the nodes in some order
you know to pick any order you know the
the nodes appear in some order in the
uh representation of the graph on the
input
you know but so in the old order i'm
just going to go through the nodes in
order therefore i'm never going to
see the same node twice um
what does step four mean
um
so
yeah
step four is i'm standing for means i'm
for each node i'm guessing that that
node is either um has a path to it from
s or does not have a path to it from s
um
so you know kind of thinking about it
the original we're at a time so why
don't i um you know i'm happy to discuss
this um in the office hours i'm just
going to skip over the rest of the
slides here um
and review like we have a missing check
in
uh
my choice let's just
uh i want to make sure everybody's got
uh
all their check-ins here so why don't we
just
uh if we know nl is
equal to coin l
we also we show to sat complement is
nl-complete it also then follows that
two stat itself is in l complete because
n l equals common l so i'm going to give
you the answer to this just because i
want to
want you all to
uh finish this
poll
still some of you are getting wrong uh
okay uh
so please answer it quick
and then we're gonna end
are we all done
get your participation points here
three seconds
okay ending
okay um
doesn't matter so here we we ran over
sorry about that
quick review this is what we didn't
quite finish as part five but we'll
finish that next time
okay when showing path is nl complete
we also need to list the nodes for
constructing the graph the slides only
mention edges yeah i kind of skipped
that but yeah you can just write down
all the nodes
um again but that's also going to just
take log space as you as you observe
yeah technically when you're writing
down a graph you write down a list of
the nodes and you write down a list of
the edges i kind of
skipped writing down the nodes but yeah
it's the same doesn't matter
so i'm going to say goodbye to you all
thank you
you